[Musique]
les touristes qui visitent paris
spectacle banal chaque jour renouvelée
mais l'image qu'il recueille avec leur
caméra ou leur appareil photographique
c'est l'image officielle la carte
postale traditionnel de la ville lumière
et monuments les avenues l'animation
[Musique]
aucun de ces visiteurs ne soupçonnera
que derrière ces façades de béton vides
un pari champêtre qui se nourrit de
fleurs de feuilles et de branches
il était une fois une maison aux murs
tristes et gré entre ses murs plusieurs
cours mal pavée d'onet au décor un
aspect d'abandon et puis soudain ce fut
le miracle
quelques années avant la guerre
un charmant vieux monsieur entrepris de
faire de ce coin du quartier pereire une
oasis souriante et fleurie de toutes
pièces il créa ce jardin de rêve où la
nature se sent comme chez elle
[Musique]
où
il existe ainsi dans paris quelques
mécènes de la nature mais il faudrait
qu'il y en eut davantage
il faudrait que tous ceux qui le peuvent
face jaillir à la surface du sol ces
petits jardins grâce auxquelles les
parisiens survivre l'exemple du souriant
magicien du quartier pereire est riche
de signification
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
non loin de là rue lacroix un autre
amoureux de la nature a suivi le bon
exemple
[Musique]
et
dans un espace grand comme un mouchoir
il a recréé la flore de ses rêves
[Musique]
ici il n'y a pas bien longtemps c'était
encore une course comme il en existe
tant mais soudain la verdure à chasser
le bitume répandant autour d'elle le
sourire et la vie chaque matin
l'auteur de ce charmant miracle pomponne
avec amour son jardin miniature montrant
le chemin à d'autres citadins qui le
suivront peut-être à leur tour car le
chemin de la nature c'est aussi pour les
parisiens étouffent et que nous sommes
le chemin de la liberté
[Musique]
il
en plein centre de la ville voici que
surgit soudain à ravissant fantômes qui
appartient à l'histoire ou du moins à
ses coulisses dans cet hôtel vécu là
duchesnois sociétaires fameuse de la
comédie-française et rival en titre de
mademoiselle georges non seulement sur
la scène du théâtre mais encore dans les
faveurs de napoléon cas mademoiselle
duchesnois fut l'héroïne d'une comédie
qui la rendit plus célèbre que son
interprétation d'iphigénie l'empereur
ayant remarqué que le plumage de la
sociétaire valait largement son ramage
la convoque un soir à saint cloud à
toutes fins utiles livre d'orgueil elle
se pomponne se fait belle et arrive au
château le coeur battant un valet vient
prévenir l'empereur qui travaillent ici
mademoiselle duché lois et d'arriver une
qu'elle attendrait pour napoléon deux
heures s'écoulent la du chinois
commencent à s'impatienter le valais
retourne vers l'empereur occire
mademoiselle duchesnois s'inquiète ou
qu'elle se déshabille et qu'elle se
couchent réplique napoléon qui travaille
toujours qui travaillent tellement que
la nuit passe et qu'ils oublient
complètement sa belle visite à 6h du
matin le valais revient trouver
l'empereur qui n'a pas quitté son bureau
cyr que faisons-nous de mademoiselle
duchesnois qu'elle se rhabille
et quel sens laïdi napoléon
depuis longtemps le gracieux souvenir de
la duchesneau a disparu mais son jardin
est resté et comme le quartier très bien
fréquentée en petit voir aussi l'ancien
hôtel de talma celui de race vernet et
celui de mademoiselle mars une autre
égérie de l' empire
et
oui
[Musique]
dans le paris insolite que nous vous
présentons il ne faut jamais se fier aux
apparences
non non vous ne rêvez pas c'est bien la
campagne la campagne à portée de fusil
de la place pigalle
ce pavillon qui date du xviiie siècle
fut habitée par des comédiens célèbres
mademoiselle flore l'étoile du théâtre
des variétés
hyacinthe le fameux comics du palais
royal
plus près de nous rabaisser un critique
dramatique célèbre puiser dans ses
jardins là qui est une nécessaire à
l'expression d'un jugement impartial a
coûté sur le boulevard c'est le bruit la
cacophonie la civilisation
mais ici communion dans une même
complicité
les habitants des lieux défendre leur
silence même les enfants semblent avoir
le souci de ne pas effaroucher la nature
la place clichy est tout au bout des
palissades
ici s'élevait alors être notre siècle
l'hippodrome un cirque géant qui
s'offrait le luxe de présenter un combat
naval puis vint le cinématographe léon
gaumont édifier la plus grande salle de
cinéma d'europe 5000 places
un écran géant de 312 mètres carrés mais
de tout ce passé glorieux il ne reste
plus qu'un trou et qu'un arbre qui se
demandent ce qu'il vient faire là
[Musique]
poursuivant notre ascension vers
montmartre nous voici retour lac le 31
octobre 1909 le sol s'ouvre issoudun
engloutissant deux passants dans les
sables mais ce drame de la nature
n'avait pas troubler le calme de la
ville à des fusains il l'a des fusains
labiano mais combien de fusain célèbre
tracé en effet les courbes de chez
d'heure ceux de renoir derain de bonnart
dont les ateliers sont toujours
frémissant de vie d'autres artistes sont
venus choisissant l'abri de ce village
en plein paris
pour y enfouir leur bonheur de créer les
pavillons dans lesquelles ils
travaillent sont ceux de l'exposition de
1889 reconstituer rbati sur
l'emplacement des anciens fours à plâtre
des carrières
[Musique]
mais montmartre n'a pas fini de nous
révéler ses trésors champêtre voici la
butte fameuse l'on raisonne encore les
lointains échos de la commune
nous sommes arrivés presque au sommet de
la colline
[Musique]
on
oh
rue cortot une adorable maison oublié
par le temps un jardin où le silence
affolés par les bruits de la ville s'est
réfugié les pigeons les arbres les
fleurs sont chez eux
impressionné le xxème siècle n'a pas osé
entrer et s'est arrêté sur le seuil
il fallait une âme d'artiste pour garder
ces lieux hors du temps le petit fils du
grand musicien camille saint saëns qui
vit ici veille jalousement sur ce
miracle quotidien un des derniers qui
soit offert aux parisiens
ainsi notre promenade d'aujourd'hui vous
aurait-elle montré ses deux paris qui
cohabitent l'un immense tentaculaire
cerné de béton et d'acier et tout fait
de fumer et de nuisances l'autre
infiniment plus petit par et de grâce de
quiétude
baignée de verdure et de lumière et
pourtant par un étrange paradoxe c'est
le tout petit pari de la nature qui peut
encore sauver le pari géant des temps
modernes
l'homme de la ville sera-t-il en prendre
conscience avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
[Musique]